As part of our efforts
for temporary residents to transition to permanent residency,
we'll have more domestic draws for us,
for the feds and ask provinces and territories
taking part in the Provincial Nominee Program
to do the same with their allocations.
This will realign our efforts
and provide a pathway for those who are in the country
who wish to stay and contribute to the country, into the economy.
Recently,
Canada's temporary resident volume has increased significantly,
now reaching up to 2.5 million or 6.2% of our population in 2023.
Therefore, in our levels planning
will be including a target
in order to reach an adequate volume of temporary residents
that we can welcome. As a starting point,
we are targeting a decrease in our temporary residents
population to 5% over the next three years.
This target will be, of course,
finalized in the fall
after consulting our provincial and territorial counterparts.
As part of our annual levels planning to set these targets,
I'll be convening a meeting
with my provincial and territorial counterparts
as well as other relevant ministers in early may.
Provinces and territories know their unique labor needs and capacity
and need to assume responsibility for the people that they bring in
as well.
This will be an opportunity for us to come together as partners
to develop plans in realigning our temporary worker streams
and bringing the people we need to build homes that we are short of
for healthcare workers that we need to ensure
Those hospitals are properly staffed
and early childhood educators.
We need to ensure people can work
and it will continue to benefit from the important contributions
newcomers make each and every day
to us.
We want every new family and resident to be set up for the success
and be able to access the services that they need.
Our ultimate goal is to ensure a well managed
sustainable immigration system built on needs
rather than profit related cost of integrity,
integrity and sustainability.